so part of the crowdfunding you know
funds at the 25 grand that you're hoping
to raise will go to set for theatrical
screenings and if more pop up they that
might happen
yeah right now we're looking at San
Francisco Los Angeles Chico California
which is where a head is from and what
was the city usually do near Nerva la
San Francisco Chico
we're also looking at Wichita and
Virginia where the director has family
as well so we're looking at sort of
hometowns and the places where we have
faces or if you try to motivate friends
to come to come see em oh okay so that's
that's where you've targeted even but
that's why okay and so for the
theatrical what are some of the
must-haves that you want for those
premiers and those hometowns people
people you know decides yeah people who
seem already yeah anything like an emcee
a red-carpet um I don't know that we
need a red-carpet
we're probably gonna all be there and
everyone so we'll talk we might do a Q&A
if people are interested we're
definitely having little parties at
restaurants or bars afterwards if we're
gonna tell everyone about and
socializing after juggler things there
was a there was a screening in Wichita
we were in a film festival named they
invited us back because they enjoyed the
film and they had a ghost tour that was
connected with the screening so if we
can figure out stuff like that it would
be great it's just a matter of if we
could find something at the particular
venues that fits with it that would be
cool so are you just googling theaters
in those areas and then finding out what
is the cost for a night run or we
run we we knew most all the areas so far
that we've contacted and yeah we're
looking at one show or one day or
possible door splits or just for walling
and seeing what happens mostly we're
renting yeah yeah mm-hm that's it for
walling right I'm using the jargon maybe
some people don't know it for a wall
like yes you want to explain it no
nothing kind of you did a great job
you